several hundred thousand people died oh
what made this war such a deadly War
it's extraordinary how many people died
more than more than half a million and
this was without a single automatic
rifle without a single bomb it was
mostly in hand-to-hand combat which is
to say the these six hundred thousand or
so people who died they died were the
person who killed them was standing
within a few feet of them
uh that's really hard most of the
killing that happens in Wars today is
actually from a distance it's by a drone
it's by a bomb it's by a rocket or by a
you know an automatic weapon and just to
make this even more focused uh to this
day the deadliest day in American
history was during the Civil War
September 1862 in Antietam more than 22
000 Americans uh killed one another
uh hand to hand uh there hasn't been a
day that deadly in American history
since then that's amazing considering
the technological changes what was in
the mind of those soldiers on east side
was their conviction for ideas was it
did they hate the other side I think
actually they were fighting out of fear
what we what we know from Reading their
letters what we know from the accounts
is that yes their their ideas that are
promoted to them to get them to the
battlefield they believe in what they're
doing but here it's the same as World
War one and I think the civil war in
World War One are very similar as Wars
you are in these horrible conditions
you're attacked and you have the chance
to either kill the other side and live
or die
and you fight to live and you fight to
save the people next to you
what is true about war what is both good
and dangerous about it is you form an
almost unparalleled Bond
with those on your side this is uh the
men under arms scenario right and and
that's where the killing goes and it's a
Civil War which means sometimes it's
brother against brother uh quite
literally and what it teaches us
is how human beings can be put into
fighting and will commit enormous damage
and that's why this happens it goes on
for four years and just the extensive
research you've done on this war for
this book uh what are some some of the
worst and some of the best aspects of
human nature that you you found like you
said brother against brother
that's pretty powerful
they're both right so the level of
violence that human beings are capable
of how long they're able to sustain it
the South should not have the
Confederacy should not have lasted in
this war as long as it did by the end I
mean they're they're starving and they
keep fighting
so the resilience in War of societies
and
um the power of hate to move people
what are the bright sides uh you see in
Lincoln and Grant who I talk about a lot
in the book as well Ulysses Grant you
see the ability of empathetic figures to
still Rise Above This in spite of all
the horror Lincoln went to visit more
soldiers in war than any president ever
has
often at personal Peril because he was
close to the lines and he connected it
wasn't propaganda there weren't always
reporters following him he was able to
build empathy in this context